yo do you want to talk about this show
the offer not just about who here has
seen the godfather anybody no yes yeah
we've all seen the goblin fantastic
movie mark hasn't you haven't seen him
he hasn't seen movies yeah
it's like a three-hour movie it's so
it's a great movie it's considered one
of the best movies of all time yeah and
it's based on a book the godfather yeah
and then this show called the offer is a
10 episode series all about making the
godfather and what it took to make that
movie yeah and the way you said top gun
made you feel where it's like yo i want
to make a movie yeah this [ __ ] made me
feel like that why it's old hollywood
and some of the stuff is like corny and
the guy who's the producer clearly tells
a story because he makes himself look
good almost every scene
but the [ __ ] that went down to get this
first of all the mafia didn't want this
movie made because it's a mafia movie
and they weren't talking about the mafia
back then
yeah it wasn't
yeah so they are like so he has to like
kind of
get the mafia on his side and get them
okay with making the movie oh did they
eventually approve yeah they approved
because he got a mafia guy in his good
graces by kind of like first the guy
calls him to a sit down in brooklyn and
he's like look i'm not gonna kill you to
prove to you i'm more civilized than you
think italians are because he's like
this movie's also offensive to italians
he's like um
what you say your side of the story and
then the guy's like look i'm gonna
invite you to my office
come read the script read the script if
you don't like it if you think it's
offensive we won't make it i'm not
making an offensive movie the guy comes
they don't have a script done so he just
he have a beginning and an end and no
middle he just puts [ __ ] spreadsheets
in the middle because he knows the mafia
or he thinks the mafia guy won't read it
he's just praying hands it to the mafia
mafia obviously [ __ ] mafia don he
looks at the page he looks how thick it
is he goes you know what you say it's
good i trust you
you say it's okay i appreciate you
calling me over here and they're doing
[ __ ] like this the whole movie then you
got the hollywood side and the producers
you got to deal with and the execs you
got to deal with and this is a [ __ ]
great show fun show where is it on uh
it's on paramount plus oh yeah it kind
of sucks because we're limited right
yeah
and paramount is the company that
produces that produce the godfather
it is some propaganda but also good good
let it be that's fine it's okay you
should be proud of yourself you made the
movie was struggling before this movie
then all of a sudden they had this they
had another movie called love story just
bang bang bang like they're about to
sell off paramount the company that
owned it yeah they managed to get them
not to sell it like it's just [ __ ]
crazy story if you have access to
paramount plus watch the show especially
if you've seen the godfather and like
the godfather is paramount plus uh the
montana show yes um yes sutton ranch
yellowstone
yeah that's the same you think it was
called
okay
i feel like you would like the show a
lot though yeah have you seen it no
like these are like the legends if you
ever read of like how hollywood was
built up al ruddy uh bob evans who like
did those movies in chinatown and all
those yeah um
no no it was all the crazy old executive
stories of hollywood and the guy who
plays young pacino and the guy who plays
young james khan yeah arrests in peace
but like the guy who plays young pacino
it's [ __ ] crazy how much he sounds
like him and looks like it's [ __ ]
crazy it's like perfectly cast i i love
the uh
the how it was made story yeah i think
like you know
for successful businesses i think
there's a podcast called how it was made
yeah
big companies and the stories are always
great because in order to make something
so successful you need luck yes
everybody needs a little hint of luck or
a few little hints of love and those
make like the best stories but the um
the godfather thing is really
interesting that they needed the mafia
to sign off i never considered that but
i wonder if the mafia is happy because
it presented the mafia even though it
was
incredibly like violent and dangerous
but there was like a romanticism to the
mafia that exists today because of that
movie in non-italians yeah so people who
are completely unfamiliar with mafia our
idea is go say hi to the don on the
wedding day kiss the hands yeah the
affection the love it doesn't get like
[ __ ] up until
is it two
is it two godfather two yeah where they
show with the relationship between dark
that's where it gets really dark and i
wonder if they would have had way more
pushback
if you know it was one well the book the
book so a book comes out puzzle's like a
struggling writer yeah and they show
this at the beginning of puzzles the guy
who wrote the godfather
thank you but he owed like mad money to
different people and then he writes his
book it sells 58 million copies it's
apparently the best-selling book ever
you just get a buck yeah like that is
[ __ ]
son that book money is different going
on and he says like to his wife who's
suggesting right about what you know in
the mafia he's like yo i grew up with
these guys you don't [ __ ] write about
them yeah and then she's like well make
the story yours make it in a way that
humanizes them or whatever but like
that's another [ __ ] aspect to it from
the moment the book came out and they
found out they were making a movie so
many mafia people uh
like frank sinatra one of the characters
johnny fontaine or whatever his name is
i when you watch the movie you don't
know it's making fun of frank sinatra
yeah i did not know that because i see
frank sinatra as this [ __ ] don god
untouchable like everyone loved them
confident charisma out through the roof
and then the characters like this kind
of pathetic needs the mafia to help him
out guy yeah and the book is centered
way more on this character so sinatra is
like i don't want this [ __ ] movie
made yeah so the second he finds out
it's a movie he starts talking to mafia
people we're like yo this is making us
look bad they don't want it made
and this is the last thing i'm going to
give away there's another scene with the
mafia guy where he's like um
can you not use the word mafia or i
don't know somehow it comes up the
producer's like you know what i'm going
to do for you i'm going to not have the
word mafia
yeah and then and then the guy the mafia
guy's like you would do that for me and
he's like yo if you want it that's what
we'll do and then he goes and asks
coppola how many times user mafia
coppola goes once and then he says
and he's like can you take that out i
just need to do it for me it was done it
was just one line well this is after the
movie is already no the movie's not it's
written uh when it's written yeah this
is another thing he does to like
schmooze over this mafia guy and then
the producer gets in good with the mafia
and then that is its own set of problems
so i think one of the things that
that the show entourage exposed yes is
that the life of the agent manager
producer people is far more interesting
in terms of stories yes than the actual
talent yeah like if you're a [ __ ]
rock star like that remember the book
the dirt about motley crue
okay you're gonna have wild [ __ ] stories
and like destroying hotel rooms or
whatever but like you're not coming
across as much adversity because the
adversity is dealt with by the team
usually yeah
it's constant adversity yes if you're
the manager there's a fire trying to put
something out the age and you watch we
watch entourage and it was and vince
almost became this like character in the
background he just like stumbles in a
[ __ ] lives a great life yeah he battles
a drug addiction for a season and that's
the most boring season yeah like all
right man i don't care yeah but the
getting it made and i talked to a person
who said that show is so accurate i
can't watch it it makes me uncomfortable
i thought meaning was like an over
dramatization this [ __ ] don't really go
down like this
yes
this lady who uh worked like behind the
camera fairly high up was like i can't
it's so accurate i can't watch it i it's
like it reminds me too much of just
[ __ ] past anxieties and [ __ ] i had to
go through i can't watch the show yeah
it's so accurate you know it's
interesting though that like we needed
vince's character that you could like
live
aspirationally through yeah like it's
it's so weird what we need like vince
gets you in the door it's like oh
wouldn't it be cool to be like part of
this thing and girls are everywhere
etcetera but he is the star yes and then
also uh the agent
right but yeah it's so interesting
without vince i don't know if that show
works you still need the guy yeah
even if he's not the focal point yeah
and it's interesting you need to really
care about him and that makes you care
more because he cares so much about yes
and ari this is like they even added
this little hook he's i discovered vince
i don't discover a lot of people i
discovered vince yeah so he takes more
ownership and vince's point so he cares
more so that raises the stakes because
emotionally these guys care so much but
i wonder if ahri's role in episode one
was supposed to be as big but then he
knocked it i heard yeah i heard he
knocked it out of the park and he did a
[ __ ] he did a [ __ ] great job but
yeah the offer also the name is good
yeah yeah the offer like i'm going to
make you an offer you can't refuse
there's another show if anyone like
actually cares about that so we don't so
the godfather was a sicilian mob and
there's a show i think i brought it up
before it's called gamora oh yeah this
is actually really cool so again it was
someone from naples his name is roberto
saviano as soon as he came out with it
he would target on his [ __ ] back on
his forehead he was in like protection
in italy for years because he exposed
the kimura and then they changed it to
gamora the the film title um
that became a film and then it's a
series it's the naples mob series you
want to watch this i think it bounces
around different networks i promise you
watch it in an italian language this is
the the [ __ ] best mafia show you
could possibly watch it's like people
have seen zero zero zero it's like that
it's like the wire yeah
and then like that mob kind of got
busted in italy and now there's another
one called that zero zero zero is uh
indrangata from calabria and they're
responsible for like 80 of drug
trafficking between like south america
and europe like it's and you have to be
like blood related so those are like the
big mobs but gamora is like the next
after you know you know the most
impressive thing about the mafia maybe
you need violence and fear
to make this work
and
yeah i'm like backing into this but um
that they can have a functional business
with nepotism
the oftentimes
the best people to increase
you know the value of your company are
not necessarily your kids like because
your kids are rolling the dice it
doesn't matter how good you raise them
some might be smart some might be stupid
it doesn't matter right
the best person to run your business
might be some [ __ ] genius that went
to mit or might be some like hard-nosed
business kid that built his way up but
there are other people out there that
can increase like what is it called uh
the shareholders profits yeah you know i
think one of the criticisms of um
dolan is you look at the executive board
and it's everybody's last name is dolan
on it you're like and oh is that why the
knicks yes
like you're telling me the five people
that can increase my shareholder profits
are related to you what a coincidence
right it's like moneyball like that
whole what what moneyball you're saying
when you're choosing the right players
right so it's like what's kind of
impressive about the mafia is they're
like nah we're only doing blood
right only sicilian period you can't be
made without being sicilian right so but
here's the interesting thing maybe they
need to be violent because they can't
compete with just blood yeah so it's
like oh you're entering my business well
you shouldn't be threatened if your
business was good yeah well i can't make
it that good because i got these [ __ ]
idiot nephews yeah that don't know how
to run a business but if i put a gun to
your head you're not even open your
business your life is online you got to
perform so if they removed sorry if they
removed nepotism and just hired like any
other business they could probably still
do the illegal [ __ ] they do just more
proficiently and then not have to kill a
single person they have to kill because
you can't count on family
i think you've got to kill either way
okay you still got to kill but did does
the
cogent does it kind of make sense it
makes sense but like you have to the
only way the knicks are going to be good
is if you start acing out board members
eight likes killing board members like
if your life is on the line as a dolan
the knicks will perform you just gotta
raise the stakes cause you can't get
fired you can't get killed i think it's
actually better that there's nepotism
because if you just brought like hungry
people it's like oh [ __ ] this is there's
no laws here i could just take out top
guys
[Music]
that's my own very true i'm gonna
respect him yeah that that also happens
right i guess that's the security right
it's the security is almost like um
royal family type [ __ ] like how do we
keep it in our bloodline like in our
last name
the concern is if you bring in these
other people it's like what happened
with like gucci and i'm sure a bunch of
other products right it started out as a
family business and then you brought in
these other people who are sharks and
the reason they're good is be as they're
sharks but the problem with a shark
is it doesn't have friends yeah right
yeah so once it finds out that your food
it's the apex predator it kills it will
eat you you're done but isn't that i
don't know i find that kind of
interesting like
the mafia
i guess the only way to sustain and
protect
the family
is with a bit of fear
or just acknowledging that there's going
to be competition and maybe life isn't
going to be also adding on al's point
who are you the least likely to snitch
on some guy you'd barely know that you
just started working for or your family
i'm not snitching on my family yeah
there's security within this america is
the thing that's like we built upon this
yeah i'm way less likely to tell on my
family my cousin's my brother i'm not
doing that
you can also ingrain values in family
easier yeah than like a grown person
that's coming to the business at 30
years old yeah so ever since they're
kids you're saying hey we don't snitch
we don't do whatever so you're curating
behavior it's religious yeah this is
what is right behavior this is what is
wrong behavior at least i can trust your
behavior you might not be smart enough
to make some money yeah and we might
have to bring some cousins that can
actually you get to raise your employees
literally
yes yeah cobala this ties actually into
the not necessarily the offer but even
the godfather when you think about why
it's so good coppola francis ford
coppola the director of the godfather
brilliant guy he reads this the thing
he's like you know how you make this
movie you don't make it about the mafia
you make it about a family this is a
story about family and that's where it's
the mafia is so family this whole thing
everybody relates to it not just you're
romanticized by the mafia but you're
drawn to it because of family everybody
is a michael or a sonny or frito or you
have a michael or sonny or fredo in your
family you know dad probably has sons
trying to figure this all out like you
have a daughter you got to be protective
of her these are all just family stories
immigrant experiences in a lot of ways
yeah even though you might not be doing
illegal [ __ ] you relate on an emotional
level that's the hollywood secret that
was like the spielberg like make it
simple even he was a producer on
transformers all he said was like it's a
story about a kid in his first car that
type of yeah that's a pixar storytelling
technique it's like every story has to
be universal
it has like every storyline has to be
boiled down to something that every
person on the planet can and will
experience
like for example coco what is like the
baseline it's like the loss of family